at a time when many Americans are
experiencing increased stress anxiety
and personal loss we must also ensure
that our country can meet the mental
health needs of those struggling in this
crisis there are people struggling
they're struggling and some people are
getting to know each other frankly some
families are getting to know each other
on a positive note but there are a lot
of people struggling on Thursday I'll be
speaking to leaders and advocates from
the mental health organizations all
across our country and we are going to
be talking about resources and tools
that will make available to them they
need help and it's a big problem when
you take something where it was the most
successful country in the world still is
the whole world is shut down
think of it we're down to numbers that
are incredible as I said yesterday I
think it's 182 countries right now 182
countries are under attack by the by the
scourge by this virus but as we wage
medical war on the virus
we're also speeding economic relief to
our people it's incredible we just had a
meeting that was absolutely incredible
with the banks I spoke with leaders in
the banking and finance industry about
our efforts to help American workers and
employers as of today small business has
processed more than 70 billion dollars
in guaranteed loans and will provide
much-needed relief for nearly a quarter
of a million businesses already so we
are going to be providing tremendous
amounts of money to these small
businesses of our country have been
absolutely clobbered and they'll be
keeping open and they'll be paying their
employees and they'll be all set to go
we're going to have a rocket upward I
want to thank David Solomon CEO of
goldman sachs brian moynihan CEO of Bank
of America Gordon Smith co-president CEO
of JPMorgan Chase
Josh our CEO of Wells Fargo Michael
Corbitt CEO of Citigroup al Kelly CEO of
Visa Michael me Bock CEO of MasterCard
Noah Wilcox CEO chairman of Grand Rapids
State Bank and we had numerous others
also on the call and I just appreciate
them they are well way ahead of schedule
by the way we're way ahead of schedule
the Paycheck protection program has been
incredible so based on the incredible
success of the program I'm announcing
that I'll be asking Congress to provide
an additional 250 billion dollars for
the Paycheck Protection which will help
keep Americans employed to facilitate a
quick and full recovery we're doing very
well we're looking very bipartisan a lot
of people want to do it and the the plan
is amazing you know they're processing
hundreds of thousands of loans and this
is the big banks that are doing it the
community banks so but the biggest banks
right now in our country are doing it
and they're they're doing it for a lot
of reasons one of them is they want to
help people